Playright CLI just released and in this
video I'm going to show you how you can
create a skill with Playright CLI and
also how is it different compared to MCP
why is it better and why you should use
it and most importantly here you can see
we have two terminals one is using the
playright CLI skill and the other one is
trying to use the playright MCP scale
and both of them is trying to verify the
Jira ticket inside of our local machine
using the CLI for playright and also the
MCP for playright and by doing so it
first read through the Jira ticket try
to understand the context set up the
user from our suabbase account and
depends on the tools that it use. If
it's using the MCP here, then it's going
to call the MCP for playright. If it's
going to use the CLI, then here you can
see it's going to call the CLI tools
here in the shell commands here to
execute those actions in our browser
headless way. And most importantly, you
can see that each step of the way here
is able to taking screenshots along the
way to document the steps that I took
and eventually it's going to create a
report like this to show you exactly
what the issue is. Is it fixed? Is it
partially fixed? And how does it
reproduce it? What are the screenshot it
took? and also what is the issue that I
found and also the recommendations based
on the report that it just run. And you
can see here that we can be able to
generate multiple reports here inside of
this folder and I can be able to see the
results and later I can be able to pass
this folder here to a sub agent here to
execute it, fix it and automatically
improve our applications. And this is so
important because with all the benefits
of Playright CLI, we can now be able to
use AI here to automatically test our
applications using the skill feature and
also with lower token consumptions and
higher accuracy compared to playright
MCP. And in this video, I'm going to
show you exactly why that's the case and
also how you can be able to use the
skills that I created for both the MCP
playrights and also the playright COI
skill so that you can be able to run
this automation QA testing before you
push any changes in your productions or
just in general be able to verify
anything. And of course, I'll make sure
to put both skills here inside of our
school community. One is for the MCP
playright skill and the other one is
using the playright CLI skill. I will
make sure to put both of them inside of
our school community so that you can
download it and use it in your
production applications. And pretty much
that's what we're going to cover in this
video. And if you're interested, let's
get into it. All right, so before we
jump in, a quick intro for those who are
new here. My name is Eric and I spent
years as a senior software engineer at
companies like Amazon, AWS, and
Microsoft. And I have started this
channel to share everything that I
learned along the way from AI and coding
to automations, web 3, career
developments, and more. All broken down
into practical tutorials that you can
actually follow. And of course, we also
have a school community where you can
get access to all the resource templates
plus our community supports. So, if
you're ready to level up, make sure to
check out my YouTube channel and hit
that subscribe button. Now, let's get
back to the video. Now before we take a
look at how to use the playright CLI and
also this playright skill let's take a
look at what is playright and why should
we even care and put it simply playright
is basically a tool like AI agent here
to control your browser it can be able
to navigate the pages clicking on
buttons here fill in the forms and even
taking screenshots and you can think of
it like giving hands and eyes to claude
or AI agent here to use the browser and
currently there are three ways to use
playrights one is the standard way which
is how developers are doing this for
many years is writing a test code file
and basically developer here can write a
automation testing through this process
and the other approach is using the
playright MTP which MCP concept start to
introduce last year and playright offers
the MTP server here to control the
browser using playright and it works but
it's not perfect and that's why the
creator of playright Microsoft now
recommends using the playright CLI here
for the shell commands to control your
browsers instead of using the MCP and
the core reason why is because it uses
fewer tokens and also has three times
more features compared to the playright
MTP. So in this case, let's dive into
why that's the case. Why is it going to
help us to reduce fear tokens and what
are the features that are introduced
using the COI instead of the MTP and to
order to understand this we got to
understand where does the page data goes
and to do so here you can see this is
the clause right the clause context
window you can think of it like a desk
and this is where everything cl think
about the code conversation instructions
all set into this desk and what happens
that if you're going to add the browser
page data here it will have a limited
space which means that the more browser
data here the less room for plot code or
in this case AI agent here to understand
the code to understand the reasoning.
Therefore, if you were to look at this
chart, you can see that as the context
windows start to grow, the AI accuracy
here starts to goes down. And that's
exactly how MCP works. They basically
try to dump everything onto the desk,
right? Everything on the desk. For
example, let's say if I want to have it
to test the login page, you know, in the
clause desk or the AI agent's desk,
first of all, what it does here is that
it have to load all the instruction
manuals on the desk on the memory. Okay,
what are the tools that we have for the
player MCU server? And then when Claude
or our AI agent here navigate to the
login page, then the MCP here is going
to dump the full page data onto the desk
or onto the context window here to show
us exactly what happens, what would we
see on the page like the navbars, the
hero sections, the login forms, all
those kind of things into the context
window. But not only that whenever claw
code clicks on anything like perform any
certain actions it would takes the
entire page elements here pass it to the
clock code context window again after
each and every single step and what
happen is that after 10step process yes
we're going to first load the
instruction menus like how to use the
MCP server for the playright initially
when the clock will start to perform
things and then it's going to start to
feed in each and every single page like
every action it took it will feed it
into the context window which takes a
lot of tokens here And you can see here
the more token it takes the less
accuracy that the decisions that it make
in the each in a single pages. And
that's really what the CLI tools here is
trying to solve is that we're trying to
reduce this amount of token consumptions
whenever we use claw code with the
playright. So instead of like saving all
the memories into the context, it will
basically write a sticky notes saying
okay this is exactly a summary of what
the pages looks like. If you want to
read up the entire page, you can simply
just open that folder and be able to
view the full page layout of the entire
page if you need this detail. Right? If
you don't need it, I won't show you
this. I won't stuff this in inside of
your context window. And that's how this
concept works. And you can see that this
will dramatically reduce a lot of token
consumptions and therefore you get a lot
of higher accuracy if you're going to
use this approach. So, same thing,
right? Let's say we're going to try to
test the locking page. We have our claw
desk. There's no instruction shows
because claw already knows how to use
the shell commands. And when claw
navigates to the login page for example,
you can see it's just going to be a CLI
command and then it shows a summary of
what that page looks like. Here's the
page. This is the full map where it's
saved, right? So this is the sticky
notes. If you're going to read it, this
is the entire page. If you don't need
it, you can just continue, right? And
then claude knows, okay, well, this is
the signing page. Now here, cloud will
need to read the file before they
proceed. So it's going to first read
what's in the disk by opening this YAML
file and try to read through what's in
it like the elements on the page, the
words, the content. And after it reads
it, it then be able to know exactly
where to fill the form and what are the
action that's going to perform. For
example, like fill in the emails, fill
in the password and click on the submit
buttons here. Then it knows exactly what
to do. For example, this is the CLI
command right here which enters the
email, the password, the click, and also
take a screenshot which you can to save
it into somewhere else. And then you can
see it going to start continue testing.
And because we only load the page
content to the cloud context window when
we need to this will dramatically reduce
the token consumption which you can see
and if we were to compare this side by
side you can see that first MCP here is
going to load all the tools that doesn't
do that for the CLI and when play right
here navigate to a page for MCP server
it's going to load the entire page data
the entire accessibility tree into the
clock code sessions but for CLI on the
other hand here it only loads the
summary of the page rather than the full
content of the page. And that will save
a lot of memory. And we only loads the
entire page if the actual like clock
here needs to find something from the
page, right? If it need it, if it
doesn't need it, we don't want to show
this in the context window. You can
think like using MTV here is going to
read each and every single page that
clot is going to navigate in the
application. But whereas if we were to
use a CLI, we save this information into
a disk or save this information into a
folder for what the content of the page
look like. It gives you a simple summary
of what it has done for each step. And
then during this process, maybe claw
will just only read like eight pages
because not every pages claw will have
to read it. And this will save a lot of
space because now claw can be able to
read through your code, can be able to
think exactly where to navigate more
accurately to test it thoroughly for
this application that you're trying to
do. And pretty much that's the benefits
of using the CLI over the MCP server.
But now once you understand how it
works, let's take a look at the
accuracy, right? What is the trade-off
that we need to know? Now first of all,
if we were to use the MCP here, you can
think of it like autopilot, right? is
always watching, is always looking out
what's going on. Like whenever it
submits a button here, the MCP here
always show the full page to claude.
It's going to know exactly what to do.
And Claude will never miss what's on the
page. Data is always forced to view it.
But now, let's say if we were to use a
CLI here, for example, let's say, you
know, claw code here is going to click
on a button here. And then the CLI
shows, okay, you click on this button,
here's a snapshot, it's being saved.
Claw thinks, okay, great. Login needs to
submit it. So now, let's navigate to
different pages. But because Claude
didn't see the full page, I only see the
summary or the sticky notes. Maybe the
form here succeeded, but there's some
errors showing and Claude might
completely oversees this. So in this
case, let comes to another table. When
does the accuracy really matters? For
example, let's say we're going to talk
about a login page for example. Maybe
the CLI here is going to be a lot better
because you already know what's on the
page. And let's say we're going to check
for a bug if it's already fixed. Then
maybe the MCP here is going to be better
because we can be able to see the entire
flow when air comes in. And let's say
we're going to navigate to an unknown
page. Yes, maybe the MCP here knows
better because it needs to see what's in
there. And of course, you can continue
look through the table. But what
essentially gives you the answer is that
let's say if claw code knows exactly
what to expect, then CLI is going to be
better. Let's say if you're trying to
use MCP here to test something that you
have no idea about the codebase, you
have no idea what it looks like behind
the scene, then the MCP server gear is
going to do better because it read
through every single step. Before we
jump into the next section, I want to
give a quick shout out to today's
sponsor, Testbrite. Testrite is an AI
agent built specifically for software
testing. And with the release of the
Testrite MCP, you can now use it
directly inside your coding IDE. So,
Cursor, Windsurf, Cloud Code, and more.
Setup is super simple. On their website,
click on test locally, then quick
install. Click on add to cursor. It'll
open up cursor and you can install it.
Done. Okay, so I have this budgeting app
I made. Let's try and test it with Test
Sprite. What I really like about Test
Sprite is that it doesn't blindly run
tests. It first reads through your
entire codebase, understands the
documentation, and validates the results
your AI agents produce. Here, it'll
prompt me to run the MCP tool, and I'll
allow it. Now, Testbrite will read
through my entire project and test it
meticulously. And then, look at that. It
generated a full report detailing all
that was tested. At the bottom, it shows
me some of the key gaps or risk. One of
those risks is that it only has
in-memory storage only and that data
resets on server restart. Okay, let's
check that out. Turns out it was because
I've been saving the data with an array.
Glad they caught that. So, let's just
fix it like so. Much better. Most coding
agents today average around 42%
accuracy, but with Testrite MCP, teams
have been able to boost feature delivery
accuracy up to 93%. So, if you're
interested in checking it out, you can
watch the video I made on it or click
the link in the description below for
more details. Back to the video. So, now
let's put him to a practical use case.
And right here, you can see we have two
skills right here. One is using the MCP
for playright and the other one is using
the CLI version of the playright. Both
of them are headless browser which means
that they don't have to spin up another
browser here to open to perform those
actions. It can be able to run this
behind the scene. And the other one here
is that these are the tool calls, right?
So you can see that the MCP here is
calling different tools. CLI here is
going to call in different shell
commands here to do this in the
background. And the most important thing
is that this skill right here, I built
it using the skill creator and I simply
just pass the official documentation for
the Microsoft playright skill, the CLI
version into this skill creator and
it'll basically read through that
documentations and also adding the CLI
patterns on the best practice on how to
best use the skill and then we also have
our dependencies. So make sure to
install the playright CLI here which
install this globally so that we can be
able to use it. So pretty much that's
the difference between the playright cli
scale and also the playright mcp skills
that we have inside of our applications.
Now furthermore there's they all of them
are using the same viewport for running
the test and here is the core six phases
for the flow on how it works and I'll
make sure to demonstrate to you how this
works later on in this video. But
essentially what happens here is I'll
set up the it basically follow the set
of the database try to run a server
provision it and try to log into the
application test it clean it up and try
to create a report based on the test
that it has run right this is the core
six phases flow that I have created
using the skill and to show you a live
demo here you can see I'm in juror board
this is a scrum board where any
production applications here you usually
track any task in this board and this
kind of board right and here you can see
I have a column here called the backlog
bugs which any bugs in our application
we usually usually listed here inside of
our Jura board. So what usually happen
here is I'll take this Jura ticket,
right? And I'll basically pass it to
Claude and using the QA uh playright CLI
skill to trigger this and see if it
actually able to reproduce this in our
local machine and then we can be able to
literally pass the report to another sub
agent here to try to fix it and this way
we don't have to test it oursself. We
can just automate this process. And
right here you can see I'm in the
terminal. Here you can see I already
have run this. And basically this is the
skill that I triggered. And this is the
parameter. So it's going to be using
testing locally. And then here you can
see follow that I basically switch the
mode here to verify. So verify to see if
this ticket is resolved or still exists.
And I also list out the ticket ID on the
actual Jira ticket. And right here you
can see it calls the Jira MCP here to
fetch the actual ticket summary or the
ticket title the ticket description and
be able to have AI here to understand
what's going on and we try to see what
to test right so it's going to plan on
exactly what to test exactly so right
here you can see it's going to first
call the suase mcp here to see if the
test user here exists so you can see
it's going to fetch that and currently
um if it doesn't exist and it's going to
create it and what essentially does here
you can see um it's going to now start
to run the test and try to see if it's
able to log into the applications using
the playright CLI commands um inside of
our claw code and then here is the
viewport that it sets here and also here
is the email the password the signin
these are all the reference elements
that's on the page that I can be able to
reference to and it basically just going
to reference those elements and started
logging in and here you can see the
login is successful now it's navigate to
the dashboard and then you can be able
to see the steps that I took and you can
see that it's actually calling the CLI
commands here to do a certain action for
example upload a file from you know this
test assets that I have in my local
machine right and then it start to
upload the file successfully and it's
able to proceed that with nestep right
which is pretty cool and eventually here
you can see it start to create a report
on exactly the findings that it has done
for the verifications so you can see
that the time now fetch from the receipt
is confirmed so basically the AI here is
failed to extract the time and there's
no option to add a receipt time is uh
this one is not reproducible which means
that it's not able to see that so it's
basically means that it's partially
complete and then here you can see this
is the issue that it finds and based on
this this is the entire report on where
we can be able to learn more about this
issue right so here if I were to do this
in the open preview here this is what
the entire verification looks like and
literally you can just pass this
verification to claw say hey this is the
verification this is the result for the
report for this ticket I want you to
look at this and try to fix it right and
this is a clear you don't have to do
this manually anymore you can literally
just have a skill and automate this
process to do it and you can see this is
the results. This is the reproducer uh
this is the reproduction steps and this
is the screenshots. We can take a look
at the screenshots here. So you can see
this is screenshot, screenshot number
one for dashboard and screenshot number
two for the receipt page after uploads.
Here you can see this is what it looks
like and we can also be able to edit a
receipt dialogue. And here you can see
this the edit dialogue, right? And also
shows the time field and also what it
looks like after it saves, right? So
this is what it looks like. So the
entire flow here is logged screen by
screenshot by screenshot here inside of
here. And what's really cool is that
because we're using the CLI here, it
shows the entire page layout here inside
of the YAML file. So instead of showing
like the entire HTML, you can see that
this is the YAML file for what the page
look like. So right here, I think this
is the uh signin page and here after
sign in, this is maybe the dashboard
page, right? So stuff like that. So you
can see that this is what the page look
like and you can see this entire page
here is no longer than a,000 lines,
right? is only like a couple hundred
lines which basically shows layouts and
each layout here shows a reference
elements of where that element is. So
let's say if the play right here wants
to click on this element, it knows
exactly what it is. This is the
reference code, right? It can be able to
reference that. Hey, I want to click on
this reference element instead of just
getting the entire HTML and try to know
where to click, right? It knows exactly
where to click by using this YAML file
here. And we can also be able to look at
the logs here and then and things like
this, we can be able to easily keep
track. And that's pretty much the scale
for the Playright QA CLI. And of course
I also run the same thing for the
playright MCP as well. So if you take a
look at this skill on the left side here
you can see this is the entire thing
that I pasted. I just say okay this is
the ticket and then can you help me to
verify this right? So it's first same
thing just going to get the ticket
itself from Jira and it start to
understand what this ticket is about.
Then it's going to create the user right
and then you can see here start to use
the playright MCP here start to do the
clicking like this signin page taking a
screenshots and people can be able to
view and here is the receipt that it
uploaded and then eventually here you
can see that the bug is confirmed it's
not being fixed. So it's also saying
that it's partially fixed, still broken.
And here is tells you exactly why. But
what's really interesting here is the
token consumption, right? So it also
generates report. It does exactly the
same thing, but the only difference is
that it's using the MCP instead of the
CLI. But the main difference here is
that you can see from the token
consumption. I think it's roughly the
same, but slightly the CLI version here
is much more lower due to that it
doesn't really eat up a lot of tokens.
But obviously the entire process of like
calling the Jira MCP or Subase MCP here
might be taking a lot of tokens here
which is why you see this is like 40%.
But you can clearly see that the CLI
version here consumes less token
compared to the playright MCP version of
this. Okay. So I spent a lot of time
here using the skillfinder and the skill
creator here to basically develop the
skill and this is the two version that
we have the playright QA and also
playright QA CLI. You can literally use
this in your project as well to automate
this verification process for your
application developments. So that's much
more easier for AI to develop. And what
I think is really cool is that you can
even embed this into a bigger workflow.
For example, let's say this is your
workflow, right? You're trying to write
it, read a ticket, do some research,
planning, implementation, and do the
review. You can be able to embed your QA
workflow for the playright CLI skill
that we just went over. You can embed
this between like step one, step two,
right? First of all, try to see if this
ticket or this bug here exists. And then
after it does the implementation, you
call the skill one more time to see if
it's able to verify the changes after it
does the fix. Right? Does it is it able
to do the fix? Right? So you can be able
to embed this into this bigger
automation workflow that you have. Let's
say you're trying to automate the
research, the planning, the
implementations, the review. You can
also embed the QA testing inside of this
workflow as well. So it's going to
automate the entire process of from
planning developing all using clock code
and bunch of MCB tools and different
skills to automate this process which is
really really important and if you guys
wanted to see this entire workflow I can
make a video in the future to talk about
this entire workflow that saved me so
much time because ideally for a
production development process you have
a jury board right you have like a scrum
board and maybe you have a bunch of
tickets here that you want to go over
and if you have this kind of workflow
and I think this will make it much more
easier to scale this so that you can be
able to add a lot more features, be able
to have a consistent workflow that can
be able to deliver a quality good
quality results using claw code, MCPS
and different skills bundled all
together. And of course, literally what
I usually do here is I'll basically have
a skill creator and a skillfinder and
also a skill refiner here on the left
side. And while it's doing this, if
there's anything that I don't like, I'll
just copy that conversation, paste it on
the left, and try to continue refining
until we have a perfect version. But of
course, if you want to see this entire
workflow, I can be able to embed the QA
testing inside of this giant workflow. I
will make sure to make a video out of
this so that you can be able to see how
you can be able to automate your
development workflows in your production
application as well. Okay, so pretty
much that's it for this video. And of
course, if you do want to get those two
skills, I spent a lot of time here to
make those skills and refine it and
perfect it in my applications. I will
make sure to put this in our school
community here so that you can download
this and be able to use it right away
for your production applications. So,
with that being said, if you do find
this video, please make sure to like
this video, consider subscribing for
more content like this, but with that
being said, I'll see you in the next
video.